uh thanks for the coming to the final uh
session of the workshop here uh to take
it away i'd like to uh introduce our
speaker uh brian who'll be talking about
new approaches to causal representation
learning time is yours all right uh
thanks for the introduction thanks
everyone for uh hanging out the last
session hopefully we've saved the best
for last
uh so um
the original title of my talk was this
um but while i was making the slides i
realized a better title in hindsight
would be this so we're going to talk
about one particular approach to causal
representation so
um before i jump into sort of the
formalism let me make sure we're kind of
all on the same page as to what the high
level goal here is what is called
representation learning
so
uh the idea is in many applications
you're interested in learning learning
causal relationships but the
measurements that you've made
talking about causal relationships
between the measurements themselves it
doesn't really make sense so a canonical
example of this would be something like
images where we don't like to talk about
uh causal relationships between pixels
one pixel doesn't really cause another
pixel
but there are some high level concepts
latent variables that can be inferred
from these pixels uh and what's going on
in that latent space might be of
interest and i should emphasize here uh
the word provably here is very important
there's been a lot of work on causal
representation learning and i'm going to
particularly focus on
proving things about identifiability and
estimation of these models
so before i jump into the model uh i
want to distinguish between sort of two
important problems that we've talked
about both of these throughout this
workshop uh so the sort of classical
problem with latent variables and causal
models is confounding so in confounding
the type of question you're usually
asking is how do unmeasured confounders
affect the inference of causal effects
between observables so
typically you're interested in what's
going on between the observables um and
the
existence of unmeasured confounding
complicates this story
uh in the setup that i'm going to be
talking about here with representation
learning causal relationships between
the observables are not particularly
meaningful
and this is the setting we're going to
be talking about so i just want to make
that distinction upfront clear
that
there are extensions of this that could
be applied to confounding which would be
very interesting but i'm going to focus
on the setting of representation
learning
so i think most folks here
are familiar with the basic setup of
bayesian networks and graphical models
so just real quick to sort of set up the
notation i have a random vector x i
associate the vertices of the graph with
this random vector i have the parents
and the children in that graph uh i will
call it a directed acyclic graph if it
has no directed cycles and down here at
the bottom we have this sort of
classical factorization criterion which
is gives us the definition of a bayesian
network so if you have a directed
acyclic graph in a distribution that
satisfies this factorization criteria
and then we call it a bayesian network
okay
so uh for today's talk instead of
thinking of the vertex set as just sort
of one random vector we're going to
break partition it into
of course observed and hidden states
uh i'm going to assume throughout this
talk that the observed variables are
continuous this is not crucial you can
make them discrete
but for simplicity i'm going to
restrict my attention to the continuous
setting
and crucially so this is important uh
i'm going to assume that the hidden
variables are discrete and the reason
for this which i will have a lot more to
say about
is that when the hidden variables are
discrete uh we induce a finite mixture
over the observables and the structure
in that finite mixture is going to be
very important to us
the crucial structural assumption that
sort of distinguishes this from the sort
of classical confounding settings i'm
going to assume uh that the observables
have no children there's no edges
pointing away from the children so this
is what encodes this idea that the
measurements don't have causal effects
themselves
um and under these assumptions i can
decompose this graph or partition it
into two components
gamma and lambda so gamma is the
directed bipartite graph that points
from h to x that's what i have in blue
on this graph
and then lambda is the dag over the
latents what i'll call the latent dag or
the latent causal graph uh that is the
edges between the latent variables
themselves
at any point there are any questions
about the setup or anything please just
jump in yeah dan go ahead
uh does
each h have to be paired with each x or
can
h's oh yeah no absolutely the
relationship between h's and x's
yeah i'll i'll have a precise assumption
on what the relationships are in in this
example
i just randomly chose to draw that one
okay yeah that's a good one
okay
so the goal is to learn
the hidden variables h the latent
distribution p of h
uh and most importantly uh the graph
lambda uh over the hidden variables
that's my goal
i'm going to focus mostly on this middle
piece learning the latent distribution
and we'll see why in just a second
uh i need to emphasize up front that the
structure of h here is assumed to be
entirely unknown i don't know how many
hidden variables there are i don't know
the size of the state spaces and i don't
know any of the relationships between
the hidden variables okay my goal is to
figure this out
just from the observed data
uh we don't have any interventions
and this model is also known as the
measurement model so i'll talk about uh
previous work in just a second but uh i
am far from the first person to think
about this model this model has appeared
uh in many applications as well as in um
the causal inference turn the causal
discovery electric yeah go ahead if i
was a really causally allergic person
would i be okay if you if from what i'd
be able to conclude from the slide that
i could just think of this as a
statistical mixture model without any
causal
baggage at all yes there are no
interventions here it's just some graph
yes
you are correct yes
other questions
and that perspective is actually going
to be pretty important that's kind of
part of the perspective we take
okay so uh like i mentioned this is a
sort of very well studied problem so in
fact uh
you can think of this as sort of a
generic latent variable model uh
recently this has kind of gone under the
guise of identifiable representation
learning there's a lot of renewed
interest in the machine learning and
artificial intelligence literature i
have to stress that this is an extremely
old topic that dates back to the 1800s
so we talk about mixture models factor
models hidden markov models there's a
ton of
literature that i will not be able to do
justice to here so i will first focus on
uh the literature that's closest to uh
this paper uh so there's a bunch of work
uh the oldest one that i found is 2006
please feel free to point out to me if
there's something before that
on
linear models in this setting so it's
the same structure that i showed in the
previous slide but everything's linear
there's also recently been a bunch of
work uh in the deep generative modeling
literature on known structure so the
idea here is that if i go back to this
slide you assume that you know the
structure of this graph and the goal is
to learn some type of degenerative model
some non-parametric model that respects
the graphical structure here so there's
been some work there
uh encore talked about baltimore
machines previously in this workshop so
that's also very closely related uh and
of course uh in the previous workshop
frederick talked about uh causal feature
learning which is sort of inspired by
very similar questions that i'm focusing
on here
so what
what do we do here uh so
the key sort of interest of ours is to
figure out whether it's possible to
identify and estimate these graphs
in a very general non-parametric setting
where we make no parametric assumptions
uh really the only assumptions i'm gonna
make are that this distribution is
marked off with respect to the graph in
addition to some non-degeneracy
assumptions uh so we'll talk a bit more
about those on the next slide uh but
these are things like positivity you
have to have distinct conditional
distributions things like this that
without you could very easily show that
this problem is ill-defined uh and i'll
briefly talk about um so the proofs are
constructive they do in fact lead to
efficient algorithms
so what uh are what's sort of the main
assumption we're gonna need to make here
uh so in addition to things like
positivity i'm gonna make this uh subset
assumption so dan this is sort of
getting to your point
uh that for any two distinct hidden
variables
the children of one hidden variable
cannot be a subset
a subset of the children of the other
hidden variables so over here
on the left you can see an example
of a causal graph that satisfies the
subset condition here in the middle
uh this is violated because h3 has x3 as
a child and that is a subset of the
children of h2
for those of you that are familiar with
the topic modeling literature and this
anchor words assumption
that looks sort of like what we have
over here on the right uh this
assumption generalizes that it is weaker
than the anchor words assumption that
has appeared in the topic modeling
literature and all of these assumptions
are necessary we show in the paper i
won't go into the details here if you
break any one of these assumptions then
you can show that this graph and this
distribution cannot be identified
without some other assumptions okay
all right so there's nothing else you
get from this talk okay uh it's this so
the basic idea behind the proof and the
result that i'm going to show is that we
can reduce this hard problem of learning
a latent causal graph
uh to two very well studied problems i
don't claim that these are easy problems
but they are well studied and we know a
lot about them so first is mixture
models
uh and second is causal discovery and i
should emphasize here that i mean causal
discovery without any latent variables
so fully observed causal discovery if
you know how to do these two things then
you can solve the problem that i've
given here
all right so how does this work
so the key
fact here so this is why i need to
assume that h is discrete if h is
discrete then it induces a finite
mixture model over the observables like
you see here
so here i'm summing over all of the
different multi-dimensional states of h
uh and i get a mixture model over x if i
take any subset s so this is some
important notation i'm going to use
in the sql
so if i take any subset of the observed
variables i could look at the induced
marginal mixture so just
condition on the hidden states
and just focus your attention on the
observables in s
i'm going to call the number of
components in that induced marginal
mixture k of s and i will denote its
weights by pi of s and the components
themselves by c of s
so the key idea here is that if i look
at these mixtures over small subsets s
so the sort of name of the game is to
restrict s to be somehow a small subset
this is going to reveal everything that
we want to know about the hidden
variables it's going to tell us the
number of hidden variables their state
spaces their relationships and their
distributions that's kind of the key
idea here
okay now this assumption is going to
sound like cheating
but let me explain what's going on here
so the key
sort of reduction that we're going to
make is i'm going to assume that i have
access to an oracle that gives me this
mixture here
why do i make this assumption okay so
understanding mixture models and their
identifiability is very well studied
this is a sort of separate question
leonard talked about this in great
detail
i'm going to sort of offload that part
of the problem to what is known about
mixtures and i'm going to talk if we
have time uh towards the end of the talk
some of the recent work that we've been
doing on this problem so i'm going to
assume access to a oracle that takes one
of these subsets as input and it's going
to tell me the number of components the
weights uh and the components themselves
i'm going to call this a mixture oracle
and note that the existence of a mixture
oracle is equivalent to these mixtures
being identifiable as long as the
mixtures are identifiable i am
guaranteed to be able to define
such an oracle does not mean such an
oracle would be efficient if implemented
but it certainly would exist
and i'm going to come back to uh some of
these examples later on in the talk
so for now let's just assume we have
access to such an oracle
uh and the main theorem uh that we prove
uh is if you assume these non-degeneracy
conditions the subset condition that i
showed you before
uh and
access to this mixture oracle then both
gamma the bipartite graph from the
hidden variables to uh the observables x
and the latent distribution uh p of h
these are both identifiable and so since
identifiability has been discussed
previously in this workshop i should
emphasize that so here what i mean is
that this is a one-to-one mapping
i'm not necessarily assuming that this
mapping is somehow continuous or
something like that i'll say more about
that in a second
okay the way that this works is that
there's a series of key reductions here
so i'll show you how the mixture oracle
allows us to learn the bipartite graph
between the latents and the observables
and in fact you don't need the full
power of the mixture oracle uh all you
need is to figure out the um the the
orders of the induced mixture moles
from the bipartite graph and the mixture
oracle
you can then i will show you learn the
latent distribution over the hidden
variables and from here i claim it's
sort of a well-studied problem to figure
out the causal graph so you make some
identifiability assumption uh it could
be faithfulness it could be a lingam it
could be equal variances whatever you
like once you know this latent
distribution this reduces learning the
causal graph reduces to a fully observed
causal discovery problem so i'm going to
focus on the first two problems because
these are sort of the new interesting
parts uh and so for example in our
experiments we just ran ges using p of h
uh and got good results
the distribution p of h will be a
distribution over discrete variables
right yes that's correct yes so lingard
just wouldn't apply uh sorry yeah i
shouldn't have said that yeah you're
right um
so what would apply i mean you could
assume faith for example
oh should that just be equivalent
yes
so that's like that like sort of my
perspective on this is that once you
know p of age you make assumptions to
identify as much as you want about that
graph whether it's the equivalence class
or something more specific than that
yeah that's a good question
okay so i'm going to focus on the first
two parts
okay so how do we learn this bipartite
graph um so there's a lot buried in here
um but the basic idea is the following
we're gonna use the number of components
uh for subsets of size at most three
to construct a tensor and this tensor
uh its decomposition will correspond to
the columns of a
uh and under the assumption that the
columns of a are linearly independent
this tensor will have a unique
decomposition and you can apply standard
algorithms like yanrick's algorithm
to figure out the columns of a and hence
the bipartite graph
is this assumption on
on the measurements
is what linear independence
this is an assumption on the
relationships between the hidden
variables
okay
so it's in addition to the assumption on
the non-inclusion
yeah yeah yeah so yeah in order to uh
yeah in order for this step to work you
need to call them
okay
uh
so that's how you identify um the
bipartite graph now notice the bipartite
graph is not really what i'm interested
in but it's sort of an interim step that
i need uh for the next step which is to
learn uh the latent distribution itself
uh and so this algorithm is fairly
complicated but let me kind of give you
a little bit of a picture of how this
works there's sort of a hidden magic to
the mixture oracle assumption that i've
i haven't emphasized yet so if you think
about the mixture oracle assumption
if i look at the mixture model over all
of the variables
the weights in that mixture
the weights in that mixture model
correspond exactly to the entries of the
joint probability table
of h
but what the mixture oracle doesn't tell
me is which weight corresponds to which
entry or which states in the hidden
variables so essentially what we need to
do now is figure out how to assign
probabilities or weights to states uh to
hidden states that's the name of the
game
so the full mixture gives us the
probabilities and then what the
bipartite graph is going to do is it's
going to work it's going to allow us to
exploit the markov property to
understand when i change a hidden
variable which observables could
possibly change
so what you can think about this is i
take the joint probability table of h
i shake it up i throw it into a bag and
the way the algorithm works is i pluck
out a random
any probability it doesn't matter and
i'll assign it let's say to like all
zeros
and then i'm gonna start
changing a single hidden state one state
at a time
and then i'm gonna be able to rule out
via the markov property certain states
and then i'm going to keep doing this
inductively until i'm able to isolate
sort of the last
state that corresponds to a probability
and then work my way backwards so
there's some careful bookkeeping here
but this runs in time
so what is this so this is the number of
hidden variables sorry the number of
hidden variables h the number of
observed variables x and k capital k
here is the total number uh of hidden
states okay so of course you need at
least order k time for this algorithm to
run
okay so this gives us uh the latent
distribution p of h uh and from here i
can run again uh let's say greedy
equivalent search to learn uh the latent
dag if i want to okay and i'll show you
uh some examples of that in a second but
first i want to talk a little bit about
uh oh yeah go ahead dan
you're not
you're not respecting anything about the
state space of age you're just saying
it's discrete
and so
um
if i
had gave you some eight if i
thought i found some h's that were
things where
i had you know they took on three
different values like zero one two and
then i replaced it with h a smaller
number of h's that just took on binary
values so i can like sort of
what what's preventing that kind of
procedure from
re-splitting by sort of adding more h's
with less complicated state spaces and
fewer more complicated states okay so so
just to be clear i want to make sure i
understand so you're saying like for
example i can imagine i have like a
mixture of three components and then i'm
gonna treat i'm gonna take two of them
merge them together and say like that's
one component
right this is this is the mixture oracle
assumption however notice that in order
for h to be identifiable itself you need
to be able to identify these components
right
so i'm gonna so so i'm gonna talk a bit
more about exactly how we would actually
figure out specifically your question
here but this boils down to the mixture
identifiability assumption if basically
what you're saying is there's a setting
where maybe the mixtures aren't
identifiable in which case this problem
is impulsive yeah does that
does that kind of makes sense yeah i
think so so are you going to specify
when you actually run if you were to run
this procedure would you specify
the number of h's and the
uh
no no you will not specify your
independence of the columns
it's the linear dependence of the
columns
of your ventures
um actually this is a good point so the
only issue is so you're right but the
only issue is i can't even i can't even
get there until i've used an extra
oracle already
so that's one so i'm already using the
fact that the mixture is identifiable
which solves dan's question but you're
right that in linear independence would
also save you
yeah
okay so yeah but let me so this this is
a great segue um so this is like the
fundamental question when you're looking
at mixtures how do you know you have
three or two components so
for example if you wanted to make a
parametric assumption that all of these
conditional distributions were say
gaussian this problem would go away
gaussian mixtures are identifiable we
would not have to worry about this uh
okay so let me talk a little bit about
that and then how we do this in the
non-parametric setting okay so
let me take a step back uh from the uh
graphical model setup uh and talk about
general mixture models which i should
point out is an example of my it's a
special case of my model with just a
single latent variable
uh so uh i will write this
mixture model that you saw before maybe
in a way that's more familiar to those
of you that might have worked on mixture
models it's just a convex combination of
some densities you do not need these to
be densities they could be measures if
you want but let's stick to densities uh
and the previous discussion we just
talked about if we make no additional
assumptions on these densities then
things are not identifiable we're in
trouble
okay so let me be very clear what i mean
by identifiability here
uh so i can
given any mixture model i can define
what's called the mixing measure capital
omega here
and what it is is a convex combination
of point masses concentrated on the
densities that uh this mixture uh where
we're taking a comic's combination over
and identifiability for me means that
the map that takes this mixing measure
to this mixture distribution defined up
here is injective it's one to one so
this is different from the perspective
that leonard and yuval took previously
in the week where they
what they want if i understood and
please correct me if i'm wrong was that
this map was somehow continuous there
was continuous dependence between omega
and the distribution here i'm only
insisting on identifiability if you want
to be able to estimate this then you
want this to be continuous somehow
that's sort of the crucial thing
okay so as i alluded to previously if
this uh family script f is parametric so
gaussian exponential random families
there's lots of other examples not only
do you get identifiability as i've
defined up here you also get polytime
algorithms sample complexities lots of
good stuff right that's basically what
the parametric setting gets you
so
what i want to focus on the last few
minutes
of this talk is what about
non-parametric sets of conditional
distributions
okay so
i sort of hid something here uh i was
talking about this set script f but for
the statisticians in the audience uh
you'll notice that this is not really
how i've parametrized this model this
model is parameterized by omega
so instead of placing assumptions on f i
could ask myself what happens if i place
assumptions on omega
so it turns out that you can avoid
putting really any assumptions on f
by putting the right assumptions on
omega in other words your mixing
measures have to be well behaved in a
specific way and what does that look
like
so in a paper from a couple years ago we
proved
that as long as the distance
between
any two of your components is separated
it's lower bounded by a number that
depends on omega okay so that's crucial
here
then
you can identify this mixture model and
you can also estimate it so this is sort
of so dan to your question uh basically
the idea is we're enforcing some minimum
separation and the separation depends on
what else is in the mixture uh and so as
long as things are well separated you
can sort the ideas that you can point it
out and say oh there's one two three
components here
all right so
um
in the original paper we showed that
there was a pointwise consistent
estimator um for those of you that are
uh interested in the finer details of
this it turns out uh that
there does not exist a uniformly
consistent estimator in general but if
you add additional regularity conditions
you can show in a paper that we we put
out last year that uh you can in fact
get uniformly consistent estimators uh
and really the interesting thing here so
um for those of you that are interested
in sample complexities
so let me go back to the gaussian
mixture model for just a second uh yeah
go ahead is that assumption
are functions of omega
uh these are these are the densities
sorry
these are just the dens these are the
component densities in your mixture well
like the assumption is posed on omega
but are you assuming you can read out
fifteen from omega oh yeah yeah yeah
absolutely that's just because omega is
literally defined doesn't that itself
require identifying
i mean
if you know omega you can read off right
but you so
you know so you so so identifiability
would say if i gave you
this thing
you could tell me that fi and the fj
this assumption is simply saying that
given omega i'm going to put an
assumption on omega but i'm not saying
this assumption isn't assuming that you
can recover omega from the joint
distribution to begin with yeah no
that's that's a that's a good clarifying
question yeah
okay
so uh back to the gaussian mixture model
setting so there exists polytime
algorithms for learning gaussian mixture
models but there's a catch to these so
yeah uh oh okay i
thought you were waving at me uh so um
the catch is uh the dependence on the
number of components in the mixture is
exponential so you can get uh polytime
algorithms but there are exponential
lower bounds on the number of components
uh and so
certain mixture models are usually
considered one of these difficult models
uh due to these lower bounds
so also uh in terms of non-parametric
non-parametric estimation we know that
there's an exponential dependence on the
dimension uh in terms of non-parametric
density estimation
now
what i claim
uh is that for this problem if you
restrict the number of components to be
two
and you know that and you only look in
one dimension
then this problem is fundamentally hard
in the sense that there is no polynomial
time algorithm that will solve this so
this has nothing to do with number of
components it has nothing to do with the
cursive dimensionality simply
deconvolving two non-parametric
densities uh under the assumption that
they're identifiable is a fundamentally
hard problem and there's no polynomial
time algorithm
was that was that
like
given enough samples it's not polynomial
time algorithm or is it that
i need super
okay uh and i guess maybe to to to point
out one last thing regarding the
identifiability so i was talking i was
talking about how you can get
identifiability when things are
separated i just want to point out that
the separation is in distribution space
not in like space like in the space
space i guess so here's an example over
here
so the purple distributions here think
of this as one component and the green
is another component so they perfectly
overlap they have the same first moments
and this is identifiable because these
are distinguishable
in distribution space so in other words
their higher order moments are very
different so you don't actually this is
not like a clustering type thing um this
really just depends on the properties of
the distribution
okay so last thing i wanted to say uh so
i don't go into all the practical
details of how we do this but uh
everything i just showed you can in fact
be practically implemented um so i'll
add the caveat that for example for
learning the latent causal graph this is
restricted to relatively small graphs
due to the computational complexity
but it is actually practically
implementable and if you focus on the
blue bars here this is the hamming
distance between the true graph
and the learned graph
so we implemented this algorithm using
k-means to implement the mixture oracle
so we don't have to do anything super
fancy it turns out k-means will do a
good job and then we use greedy
equivalent search to learn the mark-off
equivalence class uh and then over here
on the right i always like to show this
fun picture
of an example where we learned a
non-parametric mixture model with uh
six components yes six components
right
any questions so far
so one of the sort of interesting
questions would be uh to develop uh
finite sample uh efficient algorithms
for these types of problems um and that
is uh one of the open questions here so
um oh yeah no go ahead yeah
which bit of which bit of this is a or b
that
means that it's
computationally difficult
uh so if if you're referring to my the
non-parametric part that i was talking
about on the previous slide it's perfect
it's the mixture oracle that makes this
one
i mean let's be clear b is also very
hard
uh
but yeah
okay so awesome yeah
when you say
um you don't have a finite example
does this simply mean that you're
working with the
uh exact statistic yes exactly yes
that's exactly so so let me just let me
just be very clear the
this theorem
is yes this is assuming access to the
exact marginal over x
um
but these results these are finite
sample and asymptotic samples
uh so
any other questions
all right let me uh wrap up real quick
so
we talked about non-parameter
non-parametric identifiability in
linkedin models and sort of the crucial
thing so two takeaway messages are this
reduction to two well-studied problems
of causal discovery and mixture models
uh
uh uh and the fact that um sort of what
originally motivated this was trying to
understand necessary and sufficient
conditions for this problem um so we i
think we made sort of some good steps in
that direction but there still remain
many open questions regarding the
necessary and sufficient conditions here
so for example uh so one big question is
is it possible to actually avoid using
this mixture oracle it's clearly
sufficient if your model is identifiable
you have you have access to such an
oracle it does not mean you have to use
it um so one question is if it's
possible to avoid it an obvious question
for the causal inference folks is uh
what if i want to allow edges between
the observables this is a setting that
would allow me to start considering some
interesting problems involving
confounding uh and then i already
mentioned this but uh sample and
computational complexity questions uh
for these algorithms uh so uh i think
i'm a little over time so i'd like to
just thank my all my amazing
collaborators and the students that
worked on this uh with me if you're
interested in looking at these papers uh
they're available online i'll finish
there
so we have time for uh for a question
here there's one in the the audience
here
richard yes
yeah thanks a great talk i just want to
understand is there any case that
i mean i just wondering if there can be
a reduction that you can assume without
loss of generality all the latents are
exogenous meaning there's no arrows
between them
so there are some results of this nature
um
but then so like the setting that i'm
interested is where you're actually
interested in the relationships between
the latents right
so
those reductions those reductions would
violate the assumptions that i have
in the that i've made here
uh off the top of my head i don't i
don't know um but that would be an
interesting question so basically like
one way to think about this if you want
to reduce it to that case then you have
to just have one variable or a bunch of
it has to be that there's a bunch of
independent variables somehow
so yeah but yeah it would be interesting
to actually compare that those
reductions and see see what coordination
great well let's thank uh brian one more
[Applause]
you